taraji P Henson stuns in Ralf and
Rousseau at the premiere of her new
comedy what men want
that's what happens when tequila means
desperation stop doing are you reading
my mind because if you can hear my inner
thoughts I am super psychic powers you
can hear what I'm thinking right now not
you just make people to know and to see
that I'm funny
I know I've played all these dramatic
characters but I really I moved out to
California to do sitcoms and comedy in
here I mean I couldn't have planned it
better but 20 years later I'm finally
doing what I came here to do um yeah I
had a fan put a compilation of all the
movies I've done pretty much from baby
boy up until now and I forget you know I
forget I've been like 20 years in the
game and so I was like my life flashing
before me my career the red carpet
appearance comes just hours after taraji
was honored with a star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame I was about to pass out I
just I just looked over and I saw my
grandmother she's 94 and she's crying my
mom's crying and the night starts to get
worked up and it's just like a it felt
so real because you know you can go to
those Hollywood stores where you get the
little knickknacks and you can buy your
own star and put the little sticky
letters on there and so I got one of
those forever in the frame and like it's
really real like pitchman
[Applause]
[Music]